one great thing about staying young and
living living longer is that you outlive
your enemies and it makes life a lot
easier for me i i've never felt this
good i've never been this sharp i've
never been this happy
i'm not gonna say i've never looked this
good but i certainly feel young and
and great with what i'm doing what was
it you said the limbic system
don't do what it says otherwise all we'd
be doing would be eating
sleeping and having sex i know that
sounds great but you're not going to
live that long unfortunately especially
if you're doing them all at the same
time
that's a really really really really
good question no one's ever asked me
that but the answer is that
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to the show i am joined by
dr david sinclair in style magazine
referred to you as a sydney-born
researcher who is a rock star
in the longevity field in 2014 he was
voted
alongside the likes of jeff bezos and
beyonce
one of time magazine's 100 most
influential people in the world
david welcome back oh boy thanks chris
what an intro
beyonce do you ever think that your work
would take you into the
echelons of beyonce uh i guess i i
dreamt about it
it seems like you're everywhere at the
moment are you it feels like you are
no you are everywhere i i mean i came
out of
out of the uh pandemic you know with a
rush
a lot of people wanted to see me so
that's why it feels like i'm everywhere
but
not being very quiet uh even social
media i wasn't uh
as active but i'm certainly dying to be
out there
um communicating talking about my next
book
the old ones selling really well so
people want to hear what i have to say
so
i don't mind being a scientific
communicator because right now there's a
lot of
bs out there in terms of information and
i think people like me need to step up
you've
hinted at the new book what can you tell
us about what it is
okay uh so it's i have to be careful not
to give it away because someone
probably will bang it out and beat me to
it but
it's a it's a a look at how did we end
up
in this world that we live in that we've
created
and the effect it's had on our bodies
over the last six million years
technology is great but it also makes us
weaker as a species
and many of us are living lives that are
extremely unhealthy because of it
and we have to use the four traits of
humanity
that separate us from animals uh to get
us out of this mess
uh because they got us into this mess
and i'm talking about
the fact that i'm sitting in front of
bright lights staring down a computer
sitting down
uh we're all eating too much too often
uh these things we've created and
and it's beyond that actually our bodies
have evolved to be pathetic because our
technology has replaced the need
for big muscles and instead we look like
a lollipop
we're unfit for purpose exactly and you
know i mean i'm in boston
in the winter when you were here last to
talk
put us outside in 15 minutes we're
probably gonna be dead
that's that's not a very strong species
you know most animals around here
live the whole year outdoors uh we're
not
built for that anymore and there's no
going back right we have to keep
innovating
to fix the problems we've had created uh
and uh and to make sure that we continue
to
improve our lives uh and it's it's not
clear whether we can ever get off this
treadmill
when are you aiming for publication for
that i know this is like the the
author's nightmare question but when
you're aiming for it
uh well yeah probably sometime uh next
year
um but it's it's going really well my
co-author matt
laplante and i are uh best buddies and
we
this isn't work for me or him we just
laugh our heads off and
is that gonna be the guy that you're
gonna do your youtube mini series with
as well is that the same dude
that's the plan yeah so we're gonna do
some pilots to see how we work on camera
if you've read i think you've read but
if anyone has read
lifespan or actually more importantly
listen to it
matt and i kid around in between the
chapters
and you can get a sense uh of of what
we're like
but uh he he's great he's he feeds off
me he's a he's a journalist not a
scientist so he can ask all the dumb
questions
uh and then i can tease him about being
stupid that's really great
i love it okay so since we last spoke
i've
really fallen in love with evolutionary
psychology
one of the questions that has been in my
mind ever since we spoke
is the purpose to dying because i
thought that we were
supposed to be adaptive fitness
maximizers
and surely that means that having a
certain end to life is a bit of an error
like
why haven't we just been evolved to
become immortal
well we we only evolved to stay stick
around for as long as we need to
to replace ourselves richard dawkins put
it pretty well
our genes get to move on but we don't um
and that's the case we haven't really
evolved into our station in life
whales have they're at the top of the
food chain and they
can live hundreds of years bow head
whale being the longest
um conversely mice get picked off in a
year or two they don't bother building a
body that lasts 100 years because they
won't be around
anyway and with that energy that you
save
living longer you actually can put it
into reproduction which might do
and we're somewhere in between and the
problem is we haven't
been at the top of the food chain for
that long we used to be picked off by
cats and and
pretty much even spiders are in the
savannah and
what we need to do is to engineer
ourselves to live longer
we're not going to evolve fast enough
for any of us to to matter
or benefit so the length of time that we
stay alive is almost like a
um predictive risk mitigation
from our uh bodies
yeah thinking out loud i think it's it's
more like
um planned obsolescence
evolution's not going to put too much
effort into keeping our bodies young
if it doesn't need to because it could
then put resources elsewhere
uh similar to i don't know a phone these
days no one expects to have it 10 years
from now so they don't build it to last
that long anyway
and that's what we are but if we stuck
around for another 20 million years as a
species
we may evolve to live hundreds of years
but that doesn't really help us right
now and unless we solve this problem of
people getting sicker and sicker longer
and longer
and the economic burdens of that we as a
civilization
may not make it more than 100 years from
now
what do we gain then presumably if we
are sacrificing longevity for something
is it are we stronger than we would be
are we faster than we would be is our
metabolism more efficient than it would
be if we
were planned to live for 150 or 200
years
yeah usually it's a trade-off in
reproductive rates
uh you look at whales how often they
breed versus a
a mouse that can have uh you know six to
12 offspring
at once we're somewhere in between and
if we just evolved and we didn't do it
if this was not human directed
we would probably live for a couple
hundred years and
be less fertile and kids we may not
be able to have kids until we're in our
30s biologically
we'd slow all that down and stretch out
life uh which
sounds good to me that's what you're
trying to do so it's so strange that um
essentially what you're aiming for here
is to kind of jump the queue we don't
have to wait
a few hundred thousand or a few million
years for evolution to do it
to realize we're almost knocking on the
door of evolution and reminding it look
there aren't any threats anymore we've
completely nerfed our environment
let us live for as long as we want to
well yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying though i
don't know if we'll ever be immortal but
gaining an extra 15 years isn't that
difficult if you just do the right
things
that we all know are good for us don't
smoke do a bit of exercise
eat less frequently get some good sleep
have friends
these things will get you another on
average another 14 years versus someone
who doesn't
don't smoke is an important one but the
technologies that we're inventing as a
field in my lab
uh could get us beyond that so you know
we're talking about it
within our lifetimes being able to be 90
95 even 100
still play tennis hang out with the
grandkids if you've got them great
grandkids probably
um this is not crazy anymore and in fact
we've got
signs that we can not just slow down
aging but reverse it which
i'm pretty excited about to say the
least because i used to think that
we wouldn't see these changes in our
lifetime but they're happening
right now and uh it's it's far quicker
than i thought it would be
it's like uh the moore's law of
longevity research
it is and we're actually helped by
moore's law we in my lab we crunch about
a terabyte of data uh every week it's
speeding up
probably in a few years it'll be a
terabyte per day and so we rely
on that we also can sequence your genome
uh in a day for a hundred dollars
uh and can be done on a little device
like this
it used to be two billion dollars uh 20
years ago
so moore's law is helping us in genetics
as well
that's funny so you mentioned fasting
now eating
less the mechanism of fasting
how it works where does that come from
is it the restriction of the nutrients
or is it the discomfort of
feeling hungry well
uh it's not exactly clear it might be a
bit of both
that so mostly the good news is
that when your body doesn't have spikes
in blood sugar from eating
and doesn't have a lot of amino acids
around from eating a steak
it will go into a defensive mode we know
that
my lab published this in 2005 uh
from a rat study that when you're hungry
or calorically restricted we used to
call it a lot
the levels of longevity genes go up we
studied we studied one called sir t1
sart1 but now basically that the concept
is when you're not eating and your body
is experiencing low glucose and has to
make its own glucose
it will go into this defensive mode and
you want to maximize that
so i go for at least 18 hours a day
without
trying not to eat and i compensate with
tea
and coffee and the interesting thing is
i don't feel hungry anymore
um unless i'm super stressed but that
doesn't happen that often
do you need to feel the hunger i'm not
sure um
i would love to see definitive evidence
of that but it might be true because the
brain does control
aging as well that'll be interesting
right how much
of the effect of the fast comes from the
discomfort of sensing the fast and how
much of that is perhaps being curbed
by the hot drinks which you advocate is
one of the ways to kind of get through a
fast a little bit more easily
i guess it's going to be difficult you
would have to use some sort of
calorie-less stomach filling
like flumps or something too well so
interestingly uh in the
uh 1930s clive mckay and his colleagues
who studied caloric restriction
actually were one of the first groups to
report that
if you feed rats instead of food you
give them cellulose with a little bit of
food
which is the same bulk uh they do live
longer
so i you know that's why i lean towards
the feeling of hunger not being as
important as just maintaining your
your blood sugar levels at a steady low
level
that's interesting so okay so beyond
fasting
optimal diet makeup for you is lean
towards
vegetables colors stressed vegetables
and
and stuff like that if you eat just your
one meal a day what do you tend
what's that tend to look like what's
sort of typical david sinclair dinner
well there really isn't one if i'm
eating out yeah
it's getting different um roll the dice
yeah i mean i'll avoid
fried food and a lot of meat i just
can't digest it my my
bacteria in my gut don't care for it
anymore they
those those guys died out a while ago uh
so i i
can't i cannot eat big heavy meals with
meat
unless you know i train myself and i i
don't do that
so typical meal if i'm at home i might
have a little bit of cheese some
vegetables
i'll cook some up or even eat them raw
with a with a dip
usually i'm working if so nobody's
visiting i'm actually just grazing while
i work
and that's my dinner um i don't really
at home focus on making meals
um i i'd rather just uh get other stuff
done
uh but eating out here's an important
point if
somebody has a dessert you know i won't
typically
order a dessert i haven't since i was
aged 40 and that's over a decade
um ago but i will steal a spoonful of
cheesecake someone else's you gotta you
gotta live what's the point of living
longer if it's not
enjoyable so that's the other point
which is you
you wouldn't want to go from a standing
start to what i do because it
you'll have habits that are really hard
to break just putting stuff in your
mouth and chewing is a habit
ask anyone who's been a smoker about
that i think we like as mammals
we like to suck on things and chew on
things so there's that to overcome and
that takes a couple of weeks at least to
get used to
so go steadily and try skipping one meal
if you've never tried it
either breakfast or dinner um
eat eat breakfast or eat dinner but
don't do both
someone should write a protocol for that
like you know just a really good blog
post about how to
because i've seen many about how to do
intermittent fasting
but very few about how to transition
from a normal or a more typical eating
state into a fasting state you know
day day one to five try this day five to
ten try this day
you know that would be someone do that
someone can someone can write that for
us um
yeah it's an interesting one that you've
got a problem or there is a problem with
eating lots of protein in regularly
coming from a gym bro background
obviously that makes me want to
be violently sick if someone wants to
try and maintain muscle mass or even
increase their muscle mass
is it gonna have to be a trade-off
because there's a maximum amount of
protein that you can absorb within one
meal
increasing the frequency that you eat
that protein at is good for muscle
synthesis but bad for longevity
is it any sort of insight you've got
there
right well if you want to be a
bodybuilder um
especially professionals uh what i do is
is
it may not be optimal though you know
there's a fair number of athletes who
say plant-based diets
are equal or better i'm not an expert on
that but what i can tell you is that
i mean i i've built up my muscle mass on
a diet like i have
um i don't know if anyone can tell but
i'm in better shape than i've ever been
sin you know i'm back to my body as that
i was when i was 20.
um and so i don't find that my diet
prevents me from gaining muscle mass or
working out
i suppose if i wanted an extra five
percent gain
i i could do that but for me just being
healthy
fit feeling good and lean is is my goal
i'm not out to
win contests how come
that sleep isn't a hormesis stressor
like fasting or exercise
well it's an it's anti-hormesis um
it's it's necessary for for
long life and health there's no question
about that
um you mean a lack of sleep why doesn't
yeah yeah yeah why can't you because
he's saying fast it's uncomfortable it
makes you feel
it makes you live longer we're in scary
mode we need to extend our life or else
we might not be able to reproduce before
we die so
knuckle down and the same thing goes for
exercise you're under stress why not
just
why isn't sleep or a lack of sleep have
the same impact that's a really really
really really
good question no one's ever asked me
that but the answer is that the
longevity the longevity gene
that we study that's really we think
it's really important
for uh for human longevity too is part
of the
the circadian clock and when you mess
that up
either through lack of sleep jet lag or
just aging
which diminishes the clock's ability to
form high peaks and low peaks
then it it it impacts your longevity
probably because it's affecting
uh your ability to fight disease through
longevity
defenses but it's a it seems to be a
positive feedback problem which is that
if you don't get enough sleep
you screw up your aging and then you age
and aging screws up your sleep
and by the time you're elderly you're
not sleeping well
and uh you you probably you're you're
under this accelerated aging program
um interestingly that i talk a lot about
nad which is part of my research
controls this cert one defense system
and the levels go down as you age but
they also go up and down during the day
as you're waking up you start to make
more nad and if you disrupt that nad
level
you disrupt your sleep and so that's why
i tell people if they're going to
boost their energy levels do it
coincident with the clock
as it's rising hit it then which is in
the morning
because i know from experience that if
you take it late at night
you're going to bump up your body make
it think that it's the morning
and you'll you'll have trouble sleeping
you'll be like taking melatonin to wake
up and caught is all before bed it's
just not in line with
the natural circadian rhythm right but i
find
and this is just anecdotal i find it's
very good raising nad levels
uh when you get to a destination in a
different time zone
which makes sense right that that you're
able to control the body's clock and
reset it
what if it's 10 pm at night
uh where in my destination yeah then
then i'll i'll
i'll fast until the next morning and
then take a hit of uh
nad booster in the morning god and i
feel great i don't i don't have jetlag
anymore
you've managed to fix that problem yeah
for myself for sure
there's been some research into
melatonin recently hasn't there around
longevity or at least i keep on seeing
it popping up here and there have you
looked into that at all
oh well i read the literature it's hard
to keep up uh with all of it but i don't
think um
i've seen anything amazing about
melatonin in years
and when you start to see a big gap in
discoveries in science you start to
wonder
is it really reproducible or not but if
there's something new
i'll definitely send it my way and i'll
report about it
in public i'll have a look um so
sleep for longevity does anyone
i mean i can't believe that anybody in
this world after matthew walker
just and red pilled everyone on the
planet with his book
i can't believe that anyone doesn't
really value it how often
do you think how often do you encounter
people that don't understand the
the price they pay for poor sleep uh not
not very often i think i've got his book
on the shelf up there
yeah there it is yeah next to my rocket
ship uh
so it's uh it's much more i mean thanks
to
to the book matt's book it really is in
public's consciousness now i
i don't talk to everybody and i tend to
talk to people who
approach me and they're interested
already down the rabbit hole right yeah
yeah yeah
but um it's it's night and day excuse
the pun um
in the public's eye uh the value of
sleep
uh but i find that some people get
stressed out about not sleeping which
makes things worse so you have to be
careful not to worry too much
what i did was i i have one of these
aura rings which tells
when i've had a bad night's sleep and
that's not so much
to tell me that i need to take it easy i
mean i can tell
everyone knows when they feel crappy but
it's more about reflecting on what
happened the night before and
what might have caused it maybe a big
meal too much alcohol that kind of stuff
i had a uh
author on the show talking about some of
the challenges of tech addiction and
wearables addiction
is now another thing where he was
talking about um
people who have to hit that 10 000 or 15
000 or 20
000 steps a day and their husband
thought that this particular woman was
having an affair because she'd always
leave the house at 10 p.m at night
and it turned out that she was seven and
a half thousand steps under her
so she's there power walking around the
neighborhood and the husband thinks that
she's off
having sex with a neighbor or something
like that very very briskly walking to
have a quick fling that lasts for about
seven minutes and then coming back
well it does become addictive but
it's better to be addicted to that than
a lot of other things uh
i think that the future is that we will
know way more about our bodies than
than we know about our cars right now
it's the opposite i mean
who who would drive without a dashboard
but how many of us
have tracked our bodies over the last 10
years like i have
and what's coming in the the very near
future and i already am in this future
it's just
you know one of the on the you know
front row seat
um you'll have a ring you have a watch
but
more importantly your doctor will give
you a patch to stick here
either just before the visit maybe a
week before or if you just left hospital
and then eventually you wouldn't leave
home without one because you'll you'll
need it these devices are instead of
going for an annual
checkup they'll measure you a thousand
times a second um and they're real they
exist i've got one just in my
in my bag i usually wear it you push a
button it syncs with your phone
your doctor can see the results um and
they'll tell you
if you get sick if you're gonna have a
heart attack in the future next week
um they monitor your breathing your
temperature your heart
and it's uh in the us fda approved so
these are true medical devices not
not toys like these things then you say
can work out which side
you slept on whether you slept on your
right or you left last night and stuff
like that
oh yeah i mean they're seeing a lot that
you've got to give up some privacy
oh you have to say yeah this dude one of
the best things that i've heard you say
was someone can steal your credit card
once
but once your health records are public
that's for life
that is going to be health record
security is going to be a huge thing as
you get
all of these crazy insights and you're
potentially able to look
at the project out someone's
someone's life that's implications for
employment for relationships for
insurance for
everything it is but we already live in
that world we shouldn't be scared of it
no we're talking about gaining an extra
10 probably
20 years for some of us with this
technology you have to take
you know take technology for what it is
and already our medical records are
digitized and can be stolen but they're
not
so there are really robust mechanisms in
place and laws
right now about health uh data security
and we'll strengthen them
but right now i'm not concerned i think
the the benefits far
outweigh the risk and i haven't seen
anybody's
genome get hacked or stolen yet um i
am i am building a company uh that that
will tell you your biological age and
and
ostensibly how to slow down the process
and reverse it
with all the latest technology um and
i've got a website if anybody wants to
sign up and chris we can
do you amazing that's one of the early
adopters
um what's the website the website is
doctorsinclair.com
doctor is spelled out not
d-r-d-o-c-t-o-r
sinclair.com get on the waitlist and uh
you'll be
one of the first people on the planet to
have this test done um
and i'm sure we'll offer some discounts
early for for early adopters too
i love it what do you want
to be able to measure through
a bio device that currently it's quite
hard to measure
right um well first thing is that
that'll be a mouth swab so that the age
of your body that will tell your
biological age
it's just an easy you don't have to spit
it you know i mean aside from that so
let's look at the wearables that you've
got on now you can get hiv and you can
get what side you slept on and you can
get blood glucose through these insulin
things
what's missing what would you what would
you like someone to bring up the
technology to do next
yeah i know i heard the question i was
gonna get to it i just forgot to mention
the other stuff
the uh fair enough so i would i think
blood glucose on a patch would be great
rather than sticking a needle
that's coming oh yeah i've seen that
i've seen the in the middle of those
things on the back of people's arms it
looks like a
no it's a dangerous i don't know i'm not
fantastic with needles
well i don't find it pleasant to put in
you actually have to push a button and
it hammers it into your arm
and i don't like needles either i get
scared of it
once it's in it's okay but the thought
of it flying into my skin is not good
and i on instagram if you want to check
it out i pulled one of these off my arm
there's blood there i pulled it apart
you can see the inner workings and the
needle
it's up there um david sinclair phd if
you want to check it out
but um yeah what would i like to measure
i'd like to know amino acid levels
ketones um
inflammatory molecules sex hormones if
possible
um calorie counter that'd be great
just an accurate one yeah
so i don't have to think about it i
don't care
you've got an apple watch do you not not
convinced with
how accurate the daily calories are if
you were to run that through
well don't you have to enter the data in
terms of what your expenditure for the
day
or your input you're right oh no i'm
saying what's going into your
bloodstream
oh oh okay yeah no that would be like
i don't know that would be like
myfitnesspal on you'd have to
some sort of barcode on the inside of
your mouth that automatically
yeah that would be insane so i'm working
on that
i i have no idea how you even solve that
problem like what do you do do you have
like a little infrared scanner in the
back of your throat is that right okay
david said three gulps of water looks
like half an apple there
uh let's put it this way
we haven't filed all of our patents yet
so let me finish this up
but uh you know often when when i dream
of something that i really want to see
on the planet i just go do that
it honestly man it blows my mind how
much stuff it is that you do
like i i i'm aware that you're supposed
to be at the forefront of longevity and
research and getting stuff done but this
is like
even the last time that we spoke you
were talking about how
briefly yours you tend to get these um
ip sales and stuff comes through and
then it's really really good
and this is a period where i've you've
got tons of money that you don't really
know what to do with and then you just
decide to go and spend it all on
creating something else that's crazy
and you have sort of a circadian rhythm
of finances as well
and it just feels like i don't know it's
cool it's cool that you've got someone
who's
so reckless in a way kind of at the
forefront of this
yeah maybe that's not the right word to
use but uh let's say
i'm amplifying my impact by reinvesting
the dollars that i make
into new technologies uh and it's
working it's really working i've
invested in
probably 20 companies now and they're
all really exciting and they do
not just longevity work but virus
detection
revolutionizing microbiology we can look
at the
structure of the cell now in three
dimensions one of the other companies
there's a lot going on um and i guess i
just put a deposit down
and expect a return on most of them if
so far i haven't lost any money so which
is pretty cool
but um you know this is one of the
reasons i need to live longer because
some of these companies
take a while to get my return especially
drug companies
i can't believe that the main reason for
your longevity desire is so that you can
see the returns in your financial
investments
yeah it's not a very good uh algorithm
is it but uh
actually one of the things that i like
to say and it's it's it's partly true
is one great thing about staying young
and living
living longer is that you'll outlive
your enemies and it makes life a lot
easier
so i'm finding that's actually true
all right so talking about exercise your
exercise
um prescription for longevity seems like
quite a low dose of movement to me it's
like 10
minutes out of breath a couple of times
a week is that a minimum effective dose
or an optimal one
minimal okay have you got any idea what
an optimal one would be
no one does um but it's somewhere
between
running 10 minutes three times a week on
a treadmill and
running 20 miles a week um something
like that
and it's there's a lot of studies so
it's it's really hard to say which is
the optimum
and the different types of exercises
running there's cycling
etc but yeah at a minimum lose your
breath
um two three times a week and if you
can't do that
if you're too old or too lazy like like
i am generally
uh long walks are great um i i like to
lift weights so
usually next to my desk i'm moving house
but
usually i'd have some weights just next
to me um and so when i'm bored or feel
a little bit restless and i've been
sitting down i'll just pick up weights
and you know that you don't have to go
to the gym just have these sitting
around next to you
and i find that to be really great and i
do my exercises with a little bit
lighter weight than a bodybuilder would
i haven't told anybody this but this is
what i do um
i do a lot of reps and i'm doing this
and this during the day
and i do many reps and i do them fast
because that also gives me the aerobic
exercise as well as
builds up my muscle now i have a gym
so i do more serious weights but in my
office i'm doing high reps and it's
aerobic and
and muscle building which you know i've
been optimizing this for my body for the
last
30 years since i was a kid um and i
don't know if it works for everybody but
um for me i i've never felt this good
i've never been this sharp i've never
been this happy
um i'm not gonna say i've never looked
this good but i certainly
feel young and and great with what i'm
doing
we had to lift your shirt up to clean
the camera lens before we got started
and
you you're looking lean at the moment
lost
whatever it was 12 pounds since
february i found my six six-pack it was
somewhere under there yeah
that's awesome well another um advocate
i guess similarly within this space
although a little bit more towards the
performance endurance side's
ben greenfield and he tells me that
um trying to walk through his office he
says is like doing an obstacle course
because he's got a kettlebell here and
he's got a resistance band there
and during he's got a treadmill desk
that he walks on with one of these
self-powered banana treadmills are you
going to show me a treadmill desk
underneath your desk
i'm going to show you what i have under
here which is cool i don't know who
makes this thing but
what's that what that looks like a
torture machine
no oh is it a stepper is it a stepper
under my disc
wow okay yeah well i mean
if you get bored and restless i suppose
just turning around and having something
to do
have you had a look at the impact of
sitting or being sedentary
on longevity oh yeah i mean
the classic quote is uh it's as bad as
smoking now
that may or may not be true but it's
certainly bad for you i can speak from
my own experience that
i sat down for two years to write
lifespan the book
by the end of it i couldn't walk
properly i had a cramped up piriformis
muscle that runs through your hip bone
and it took about
over a year to fix it and uh that's just
one example
of of the problems you can have from
sitting but you know if you're sitting
it means that you're not
moving your heart you know training your
heart that's the main problem
and also you get the obesity that comes
with it or the weight gain
and there's very few things in this life
you can do to accelerate
your body's clock faster than to gain
a lot of uh white adipose tissue or or
you know fat on your body
now i'm not you know telling everybody
they have to be
you know have a six-pack that's not
really the point that's it that's a
choice
um but you want to maintain a healthy
weight um bmi for me
optimally looking at the science is
around 23.
um different races and sexes are
different of course
but the point is that there is an
optimal weight for longevity that you
can hit
i write about it in lifespan if you want
to look up the references and all of
that
but i was talking about this with joe
rogan just last week
that you know we talk about
being healthy weight and lean and and
and optimizing our bodies not because we
want to shame anybody else who isn't
i mean i've been pudgy for some of my
life
what we we do it out of love we really
just want everybody
to feel the way we do and have the
confidence that we do
and that comes from working a little
hard
sometimes going without some things that
you'd love to eat or do
or doing some things you don't want to
do but in the end it's so much
it's so worth it and the gains you get
at the end of your life
uh will really make it worthwhile but
think about anyone that's in a new
that's found a new productivity app
right or joined a cult
or joined a new religious movement that
they
makes them feel whole makes them feel
good they become evangelists for that
movement right
dude you got to try this new note-taking
app you got to try this new workout you
got to come to this new
nightclub or whatever it might be
because i want you to experience the
thing that i've had
then you are right it seems like um
for some reason the empathetic position
in terms of trying to get people into a
position of health
doesn't really seem it doesn't feel like
that gets sort of
felt it feels dictatorial and oppressive
as opposed to
empathetic and encouraging
yeah well you and i are trying to hit
the right tone here
and and i think that it's worth saying
again
it's hard to go from a standing start to
extremes you just have to
do better every day and you'll fail some
days
i'm not perfect um and nobody is
but as long as you keep at it it's all
about every day
trying to do better um and in fact that
that's
that's the goal in life anyway at
everything you do but for health it's
really important because our bodies are
trying to fight us
our bodies want to sit down they want to
eat sugary and fat
fatty foods and the food industry
designs the food
to activate those pleasure centers so it
you know we've got
got the uh the marketers and and uh food
producers against us
and i'm trying to even level the playing
field here
what was it you said [ __ ] the limbic
system yeah
that's right don't do what it says
otherwise all we'd be doing would be
eating
sleeping and having sex i know that
sounds great but you're not going to
live that long unfortunately
uh especially if uh if you're doing them
all at the same time
so what about emotional well-being
what how does that relate to longevity
obviously it's very messy
i guess as someone coming at it from a
more scientific perspective is that
harder to study
uh what is so emotional well-being
relating to longevity
yeah i see what you mean uh it's really
important because
the there's a certain amount of stress
that's mental stress that's good for you
um keeping on edge having a purpose in
life
being excited that's all good but you
can overdo it and have
anxiety a lot of people do especially
having come through this panda
pandemic that'll release cortisol among
other inflammatory stimulators
which will accelerate aging there's
really no question that an animal that's
stressed
lives shorter um if anyone who's kept
a fish in an aquarium can see that the
stressed out fish that get picked on
not only are smaller and have less color
but they don't live as long either
so you don't want to be that fish and so
what i've done
to use myself as an example is work very
hard to overcome my
anxiety i am naturally anxious i'm an
overachiever
i worry about every mistake that i make
even a misspelled word on an email
but i've had to realize that life isn't
that serious you know a serious day is
when
you see one of your family members die
in front of you and that happened to me
everything else it's a good day you know
if you wake up in the morning
your heart is beating uh you've got
friends you've got your health
it's it's a good day no matter what
that perspective's so important and it
really is
difficult i think to keep a hold of that
especially over the last year
everyone's got so neurotic right less
novelty less
time around other people less being
taken out of your own head
well yeah it's been said and i agree
that that mental health
is going to be the disease of the 21st
century because we've taken care of a
lot of other issues
um but the world we've built around us
topic of my next book
is extremely stressful there's no doubt
and and social media contributes to that
and it's designed to be addictive
um you know myself i'm on social media
and i have to be very careful not to
get distracted by it too much because
there's actually there's actual work to
do [ __ ] to be doing
yeah and 150 000 people die every day
from age related diseases so
i got to focus um but anyway the the
stress is there and it's nobody's fault
but there are ways that we can overcome
it there's
mental exercises there's meditation
there's breathing
uh these are these are things and online
therapy
is really taking off uh and so if you if
you do need help
check those out because i think they're
gonna be a real revolution in mental
health
betterhelp.com modern wisdom for 10 off
your first month
um i read a study
calling it to study is is giving it far
too much credence but i read an article
that said that um people without dogs or
families
die soonest people who have families
live longer
people who have families and dogs live
longer again but people that only have
dogs live longest of all
do you think that's true
gee i know that having a dog makes you
live longer
i know that having friends makes you
live longer and that date is really
clear
looking at people across their life i
didn't know that just having a dog makes
you live longer
has anyone thought that it might be the
friends that are holding you back that
are just a byproduct of the dog the
dog's got friends you gotta walk the dog
with the dog's friends
get rid of the friends sweet you and the
dog
yeah you know i'll give you a scientist
interpretation
dogs don't lie to you and we spend a lot
of our time worrying about
motivation and is someone going to be
loyal
are they going to reciprocate dogs are
just there you don't have to worry so
that
that whole part of being a human and
interacting with humans
if you take that out of the equation i
bet you you lead a much less stressful
life
i think as well having an animal that is
dependent on you i'm still just all
about chris mostly
but the times that i spend around
my buddies that have got kids or dogs or
whatever
it really does just force you to
remember like i am not all that's going
on in the universe there is other things
out there i can focus my attention on to
this other animal that's
dependent on me and i've got to look
after it and it has
needs it's not just about you and i
guess that that neuroticism that
overthinking that over
assessing of what's going on it's going
to help you to to get that down so
having a dog is a mindfulness exercise
is what i'm saying
yeah for sure and it gives you purpose
having a purpose in life
is definitely helpful and if you don't
have a dog or you don't want a dog
find what you love and just do that and
you'll live longer and you know it's a
it's a great thing when you can do it
and that's another reason to have longer
lives healthier lives
because if you don't like the career
that you started in your 20s
take some time off and start again you
at 50 you know
i could potentially have another 50 to
go just getting started
didn't your dad change his career at 72
or something like that
yeah he's closer to 76 actually and he's
still going strong at 81.
yeah he's a real beacon of hope i call
him
good example to set have you been able
to study the effects of loneliness or
companionship on your mice
is that something that you can do or is
it is it kind of hard
um we haven't but we do cage mice either
separately or in groups i haven't seen
that it makes a difference
um but then again i haven't paid
attention
either uh next time i come on i'll have
the answer for you i'll i need to text
someone in my lab
uh who actually does the the real work i
just get to talk about it
yeah i get you you mentioned i think it
was on rogan's show where you said that
um
sort of under the age of 25 you thought
that um supplementation
and things like that perhaps were not
quite so necessary at least with regards
to i think
specifically nmn or nad boosters and
stuff like that
if you were you know 20s to sort of
early 30s would it just be focusing on
diet training finding yourself some good
friends and
and sort of getting some life skills or
is there something else that you do
uh get a dog yeah yes get a dog everyone
this is the front end of the funnel for
dogs
affiliatelinkdogs.com modern wisdom
10 off your first dog yeah well um
we're also building a company uh that
has dog longevity products
uh supplements so what watch out for
that
uh but yeah in your 20s i usually go by
what's worked for me
in my 20s i was a gym rat i did aerobics
i did yoga
i watched what i ate i didn't eat
breakfast i tried not to eat
too much bad food you know but as a 20
year old you can eat pizza once in a
while
so that that worked for me and i think
that it makes sense given that
the body's protective defenses against
aging are still pretty high when you're
young nad levels are higher
so you should be okay um
can i say that would would not help to
supplement
no we don't have any idea but it's i
think it's more important to start
in your 30s based on my experience um
and you know there is still a risk with
all supplements there's no molecule
that's perfectly safe
even fish oil i think has warnings on it
so
um if you're 20 and you're going to do
this for your whole life that's a
greater risk
than someone like me who's 50. you could
argue
yeah that's interesting because out it
details the extremes of your usage if
there is a
negligible background risk to something
that you're using if you use it
five thousand times instead of ten
thousand times likelihood if that risk
has been chopped in half right
it is but if it's still only one in a
million or one in a billion it
doesn't really matter i mean we know
what's going to happen to us if we don't
do anything
and that's that's tragic and scary um so
you know in terms of weighing up the
risk i don't understand people who say
oh
i don't want to take take resveratrol
because we don't have any proof that it
works
well dude it costs two cents a day
it's never hurt anybody as far as we
know and what's gonna happen if you
don't
so that's fine but i'll miss you when
you're gone
can we go through your daily supplement
routine now we did one two and a half
years ago and i'm
really interested to try and compare so
morning to night what are you
what are you currently taking uh doses
and such like
yeah well actually it hasn't changed
since i wrote a lifespan
18 months ago so page 304
see the list um i've added a few things
i work out more
i'm doing more weights three times a day
supplementation still nmn
resveratrol some metformin uh
spring the baby aspirin definitely
that's if nothing else protective
against colon cancer but probably other
stuff too i like to keep inflammation
down that's a
hallmark of aging um so i've added
um quercetin which is a molecule related
to resveratrol
which is also suppresses the activity of
senescent cells um and there's another
one that i'm
experimenting with uh to have a look
what happens
and i trust me i'm i'm i'm a doctor
right
i'm a phd i monitor myself
i know my body better than probably
anyone on the planet
a few exceptions but i i know when
something
negatively affects me or positively and
so i can do these experiments on myself
so
the the one that i'm testing out is
physique and f-i-s-e-t-i-n
and physique we showed in 2003 and 2005
in two nature papers that it extends
the lifespan of animals uh small animals
worms and flies but nevertheless it's
been
now shown that it's cenolitic it kills
off the senescent cells in the body
at least in mice probably in humans
based on some
human data and so i'm looking at that um
other than that that that's my life i i
definitely eat less now i've sk
i'm skipping lunch not just breakfast
routinely and really
enjoying that have you got any idea what
sort of calories typically on a day you
would
end up eating total no
i probably would have a
one drink so probably either a red wine
or a whiskey at night
with a salad some cheese a little bit
maybe a bit of shrimp
maybe some chicken if i'm eating out but
probably not often
but that's it i tend not to eat more
than
half a regular meal at dinner compared
to what i see everyone else eat
and that's once a day once a day yeah
wow
and then i'm chewing on gum and drinking
tea the rest of the time
i do have a bit of yogurt in the morning
which i freely admit
it's just to mix your resveratrol in
right yeah because the
all these molecules the polyphenols that
come from plants question
physique um resveratrol even curcumin
especially curcumin they're like brick
dust they don't they don't get absorbed
they're crunchy so you have to mix them
with something olive oil or yogurt
so that they they get absorbed and i
know this from human clinical trials i'm
not just making this stuff
up and if you so if you have resveratrol
with a bit of
food and fatty food you get five times
the levels in the blood
one of the things that i was really
fascinated by after our first
conversation
was how passionate people were
in the comments section and also
messages and and stuff that
i got and then further conversations
about longevity that i've had over the
last couple of years
do you notice this sort of within the
longevity community that there is
it's quite a animated
group why do you think that is
uh well it's it's certainly growing the
number of people that are into this
and excited by it um and the number of
people who've now read my book which is
it's going to be close to a million by
now across the world in 20 languages
which is
really mind-blowing
um so there is this um zeitgeist uh or
you could call it a mega trend of people
caring about their bodies and and
realizing that aging
is in their own the pace of aging is in
in our own hands
i i like to say 80 of it is based on
studies of twins
but yeah they're very enthusiastic and
we're getting more and more enthusiastic
because the technologies and the
discoveries and the knowledge
about how to slow down and even reverse
aging
are coming out fast and furious and i
i'm trying to read them
sort through them and give the best of
them
out to the public on social media but it
it's head spinning what's happening
you know this paper that we published in
december in nature which
and i have a copy here pretty excited we
got the cover
so here we go turning back time
reprogramming retinal cells
can reverse age-related vision loss this
is this thing that you did in
mice whose uh retinas you'd crushed
right and then you
yeah it's even better than that we can
rebuild
an optic nerve but we treated glaucoma
and also we just took old mice that were
blind
and for the first time restored their
vision back to normal so what this tells
you is you can reset the age of a tissue
without any issues
that tissues that are old and we think
are
gone are recoverable and so what this
tells us is that aging
first of all there's a backup copy of
the information to be young again
stored in our bodies somewhere we are
looking for where it is but there is a
reset switch that we
found and that as long as you know the
trick it's really easy any student
even a high school student could do this
experiment preferably not on them
on their parents but uh it's not that
hard
once you know and i think we've we've
reached a turning point
in being able to control the pace of
aging in my lab
we can accelerate aging in a mouse we
can reverse it
we're reversing age not just in the eye
now but in the ear in the brain
recovering the ability to learn
so that this is super exciting and it's
taking
the academic world by storm there are a
lot of labs that have
jumped into this field at least four
nobel prize winners are now working on
this
who won awards for different things but
now are working on this
and more money coming in than ever
before both in labs but also in
companies there's a lot of investment
so all of this i think i think if we
look back at the history of the 21st
century
this will dominate the first 20 years
and then what i'm talking about will be
the most exciting thing over the next 20
years
is everyone just holding on to your
coattails
you mean riding them or holding them
holding them just desperately trying to
keep a hold of
of whatever you're doing and thinking
like yeah well you've got all of these
new people coming in investment money
researchers
well yeah i'm certainly uh trying my
best to
to bring the world along with me but i
can't take credit for it
there's hundreds of researchers around
the world seriously
and they don't go on podcasts so you
don't hear about them as much but
they're there and they've worked really
hard
and they're brilliant and we when we get
together it's an amazing synergy because
often we're working on different pieces
of the puzzle and they're finally coming
together
into one single hypothesis that
hopefully can explain why we age and as
i wrote in my book why we don't have to
what your thoughts on the covet vaccine
have we got any sort of
concerns there uh no
no no nothing serious um i
talked a lot about covert in the
beginning of the pandemic and then uh i
noticed yeah and then
and it really sort of you seemed like
you'd done your work and then stopped
well like a lot of people um who had
kids i needed to focus on my family so i
did that
and they're all good and so i'm back
back out
but uh so i know enough to be dangerous
about kobe the vaccine i know the
people who make literally invented and
the people who make the the moderna
vaccine
good friends of mine um there's
it's not a concern i mean seriously if
you're worried about that
you should be worried about crossing the
street um there's
it's it's more likely you'll get hit by
lightning than something bad will happen
to you
from a vaccine there's there's no chips
from bill gates in them
it's a miracle of science and we should
embrace it you know scientists have
saved the world here
we would have been done for we've lost
many many millions tens of millions of
lives if there wasn't a vaccine
so i i really don't
subscribe to the idea that uh we should
avoid vaccination
or we we may as well just go back to the
middle ages what about 5g
everyone's got problems with that having
you 5g
phone nearby or in your pocket i've
certainly seen some
videos and stuff in terms of the
radiation that comes off them
how does that affect longevity well we
don't know we don't even know how
how going through those airport scanners
affects longevity
i try to avoid them if i can i so here's
a funny story i need to interject that
you told me you told me that you
request a um manual
search whatever it's called i won't i'd
rather not go through the scanner i'll
take this thing um flying out of boston
leaving your very office and your lab
i i requested that very same thing to
which the security guard looked at me
said are you sure sir
i said yes put my bags in the thing and
tried to take me into a side room in
which i would have had to have fully
stripped down
unbelievable i can't believe that you
tried to stitch me up
to get me to go into a room no
i'm adamant i thought to myself that dr
david sinclair
has tried to stitch me up so that this
big burly man takes me into
a room and makes me take all my clothes
off well you're on to me you do know it
was april first when you visited
[Laughter]
but uh i i've gone through scanners
because currently my clearance isn't
isn't updated
uh and i wear this patch on my chest and
they freak out
when they see i've got a flashing light
on my chest they think i'm iron man or
something
not far off um okay so 5g is going to be
all right then we're not we're not
concerned yeah
i'm not worried i've looked at the data
there's nothing that concerns me
there is radiation i think we should
study it but i
i don't think there's any evidence that
it's going to be harmful it doesn't
damage dna which is what
my main concern is because that will age
you what about bluetooth headphones
stuff like that same
yeah same that's it's low-dose radiation
you know
you can you can worry about this stuff
um
or you can just get on with it the
scanners
i particularly worry about because at
least the early versions of those
machines had penetrating
radiation at a wavelength that wasn't
healthy and europe banned them before
the us did
um and so i don't panic if i have to go
through the scanners these days but
just if i have a choice and i can skip
it i will but yeah for phones and all of
that bluetooth
now but i would like to test various
radiation
um types on mice for their lifespan
because you've hit on a good thing which
is often whether it comes to
radiation or molecules that are in the
in the
environment nobody tests the longevity
of an animal because it takes too long
takes
three years and so even while short-term
it doesn't have any effect
it might speed up aging or do something
else
yeah that's an interesting one i found
out that uh a 20-minute phone call
with your phone to your head is the same
as being in
a room with a wi-fi router for an entire
year
so that was an interesting comparison in
terms of the amount of radiation that
comes off
right well if it doesn't change the epi
genome
and that is what i believe drives the
majority of aging
then i'm not concerned but that's a good
good experiment actually chris
we could take these emitters whether
it's a phone or a router
or maybe even a scanner at the airport
and put just put cells in there
and see if it disrupts the epigenome
structure so the three-dimensional
structure of dna
and if it does then then we probably
should be testing a mouse or
two but if there's no effect it'd be
great to publish that because i think
that that would allay a lot of fears my
first published paper i can't wait is
this what you do do you go to bed do you
go to bed at night and think like what
my what mad experiment am i gonna do in
the morning the same way that i go to
bed thinking of
questions for podcast guests you just
think about what might experiment about
longevity you're gonna do the next day
of course that this is what i'm paid to
do but then you have an army of people
that just go and do it you just what do
you do you what's up someone and say
right i want to put can we put some
cells in the scanner please
ring the airport see if we can get a
hold of one make it happen
yeah i tend to be pretty stubborn if i
want to do something i won't stop till
it
somebody says yes so yeah i've already
looked into it you can get these
scanners
uh they're fairly expensive but they
that they have them around the place
i know people at nasa could probably
call get all the ones from europe that
they banned
get those they'll be flogging them yeah
that's right
they're probably in some uh eastern
country who knows but um
well i think we do need to have the
government pay for this
every time there's there's new radiation
look at
the rate of aging in an animal that
would be great
because i think most it's not on
anybody's radars use the
the other pun that that this could
affect the aging process
and how would you know unless you tested
it
i saw on your instagram something about
being able to stop or reverse gray hair
what's going on there oh
yeah so that wasn't that was another lab
that did that but it was really
interesting so that
there are people it's pretty common
actually that people can go temporarily
gray from a lot of stress in their life
and so the hair will start to grow gray
out the bottom and then
if they relax go on our vacation it'll
go black again or brown
and you get this hair that's brown gray
brown they've got roots coming through
on a a really bad hair dye
yeah it could be uh anyway so the this
researcher and his team plucked these
hairs out
and looked at what was going on at the
molecular level
and could see that there were changes
that were associated with aging and its
reversal
and which is exciting because if we can
understand how this happens we could
not just reverse gray hair uh but also
other aspects of aging in the body and i
like that idea that you can use hair as
a model
for age reversal it's easier than
restoring eyesight put it that way
you tweeted the other day saying life's
a journey pick a worthwhile destination
what's the destination that you're
working toward
uh well it's really simple that the
world is a better place
um down one level from that that
everybody in the world can live a better
life um
a healthier life longer life because of
something that i did
uh more practically it could be as
simple as
writing my books to give people advice
on how to take their life into control
under control and uh ultimately i'd love
to have a medicine or two that
can treat diseases and aging itself
um and i feel like something is i mean
the book lifespan certainly was was more
popular than i
ever imagined so i can tick that one off
the list
but the destination really
it's an interesting destination because
i don't know how far into the future
we can go i'm i'm not making this up as
i go along but
it is changing with every week new
discoveries that are coming out in my
lab and others
that are pushing that destination
further out into the future and allowing
me to do things
with my life that i never thought that
i'd have the chance to do
you and beyonce mate
david sinclair ladies and gentlemen uh
people want to keep up to date with your
stuff
where should they go also that
we you can donate as little as 10 bucks
to my lab to help us buy some of this
data
our state of art equipment that's
sinclair lab sinclairlab.com
and then on social media um twitter
is david a sinclair and instagram is
david
sinclair phd and i try to be as
entertaining and educational as i can be
and oh chris these these sayings
somebody wrote a negative thing
as you do on twitter that oh scientists
think they're philosophers now
uh yeah we do but not only that these
are sayings
if you read them these are what i teach
my students and i figured why
just train 20 people at a time when i
can give it to
potentially millions i love it man until
next time
i love to come back thanks chris this is
awesome as usual
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace
you